there um this this series we've been
doing it annually this is our second
year and it's sponsored by the uh Yale
Center for environmental law and policy
which is the center that I run and by
the way I'm Josh galprin the associate
director of the center for environmental
law and policy also sponsored by the
Yale climate and energy Institute and
tonight we are particularly thankful to
Professor Susan Clark who came up with
the idea of bringing Todd Wilkinson to
campus for this talk um Todd is an
environmental journalist he's had 25
years of experience he's got a couple
books and he's here tonight to talk
about his book Last Stand Ted Turner's
quest to save a troubled Planet it's an
interesting take I think on the climate
and energy bookshelf series because it
is not primarily a climate and energy
book it's a book about Ted Turner's uh
unique perspectives and unique efforts
to uh to conserve land particularly in
the in the American West but um you know
it's it's an it's an approach that is
still relevant to climate uh many know
that Ted Turner has a strong unions on
nuclear power an energy issue and land
conservation the way we live and use our
land it's very relevant to climate and
energy more generally so I'm glad to
have a speaker who can talk a little bit
about something other than International
climate negotiations or Energy
Efficiency you know
um the ipcc and so forth we're gonna
have a different perspective tonight
which is really great
um and also a perspective that that
focuses not just on the issues and the
ideas but on an individual person Ted
Turner who is definitely unique and has
definitely uh gives
I I won't necessarily say great lessons
although we'll see what Todd but what
Todd thinks but interesting lessons on
how to how to make change happen and
it's not changed that all of us can make
uh for better for worse but it's it's a
left a lesson worth
um worth paying attention to so Todd I'm
going to let you come up and and talk uh
talk about the details here but thank
you very much for joining us
so it it's great to be out here and
you'd be surprised I I live in Bozeman
Montana and the number of yales who
continue to influence public policy and
the environment in that region it's
pretty impressive it includes
journalists people in Academia the NGO
Community I mean virtually every issue
that I write about in the west there's
some sort of connection from somebody
who's flown uh has somehow uh come here
or been here in some way and uh
Susan Clark I've known going back 25
years to when she was involved with
black-footed ferret the rescue of the
species as you know the most endangered
land mammal in America
so what I want to talk about tonight is
this character Ted Turner
and the title of the talk is can
capitalism save the world and I really
want to talk about Turner not the media
man
um but someone who I really uh consider
a potential Pathfinder as an
eco-capitalist
and so
to begin
you know there's the premise
is capitalism the problem I think
everyone here would say yes what Turner
would tell you is that
capitalism isn't the problem democracy
isn't the problem but how we've been
practicing them
and so who is this guy
um 20 years ago I went out to his Ranch
he had first moved to Montana
and he had booted all the cattle off and
replaced them with bison it's a ranch
000 Acres extends from the Madison River
to the Gallatin those rivers are best
known if you saw the movie A River Runs
Through It uh it was filmed on both of
those Rivers
Turner buys this piece of property he
boots off all the bikes or all the
cattle he brings in bison he talks about
how unhygienic cattle are he Riles the
rant Ranchers
and attracted a lot of enmity
but one of the things I want to do to
begin with
in order to understand Turner you have
to understand
the childhood that he came out of and I
I want to begin with something
uh just to read you a letter
this is a letter that was written by Ted
Turner's father Robert Edward Turner II
to Robert Edward Turner III Ted Turner
who was a student at Brown University
here it begins
my dearest son
I am appalled even horrified that you
adopted Classics as a major
as a matter of fact I almost puked on
the way home today
I suppose that I am old-fashioned enough
to believe that the purpose of an
education is to enable one to develop a
community of Interest with his fellow
men to learn to know them and to learn
how to get along with them these
subjects might give you a community of
Interest with an isolated few
impractical dreamers
and a select group of college professors
God forbid
there is no question but this type of
useless information will distinguish you
set you apart from the doers of the
world
if I leave you enough money you can
retire to an ivory Tower and contemplate
for the rest of your days the influence
about the hieroglyphics of prehistoric
man
and what they had upon the writings of
William Faulkner incidentally he
Faulkner was a contemporary of mine in
Mississippi we speak the same language
strong words and strong
Deeds I just wish I could feel that the
influence of those Oddball professors
and the Ivory Towers were developing you
into the kind of man we can both be
proud of
I think you're rapidly becoming a
jackass
and the sooner you get out of that
filthy atmosphere the better it will
suit me you go ahead and go with the
world and I'll do it alone
I hope I'm right you're in the hands of
the Philistines and God damn it I sent
you there I'm sorry
so this letter was written
Ted Turner was booted out of brown twice
the first time was for fraternizing with
women chronically in his dorm room
the second time
he was booted out because in part his
dad refused to pay his tuition and so he
had to leave brownie never graduated
now one of the things the ways that Ted
Turner exacted revenge is he took that
letter
and he published it in the school
newspaper at Brown which assured the
fact that his dad would not continue to
pay his tuition
but that's the kind of background that
Ted Turner came out of
and so what I want to talk tonight about
in addition to eco-capitalism is I want
to talk about places and how it can
transform people
this is the flying D Ranch in Bozeman
outside of Montana it's the ranch I
mentioned this is a view outside his
window overlooking the Spanish Peaks
which formed the northern extension of
the Madison mountain range
and so I want to talk about invention
invention as in the things we do the
ideas we have but I also want to talk
about reinvention which the way I think
of it is is what you do when you realize
how you can make a positive influence on
the world
oftentimes these moments don't arrive
until you have resources to make a
difference
I also want to talk about the triple
bottom line
and moving it from abstract to actual uh
having it applied on a land level
so here's Ted Turner
who is this guy
let's explore that first
a couple things that connect him he has
a restaurant chain 40 some restaurants
Ted's Montana Grill it serves bison on
the menu
eat eat great do good
he's influenced these guys
he's involved with this
he founded that for those of you who are
millennials part of the millennial
generation he founded this cartoon
series in the early 90s because he
wanted to develop a cartoon series that
would influence you
he's involved with this
he's been involved with him
Ann bison
so about eight years ago I started
working on the book I I a couple of
ground rules that we had one is I had
unlimited access to Turner I could ask
him any question that I wanted to he
couldn't edit my manuscript he in turn
gave me an assignment he said I want you
to visit all of my properties Turner
owns two million acres of land he's the
second largest landowner in the country
second to John Malone
but one of the things I discovered is
that people have a tunnel vision view of
Ted Turner this is Ted Turner at the
first Ranch he bought in Montana called
the bar none
now one of the things I want to point
out is that Ted Turner does not think of
himself as Saint Francis reincarnated
I don't portray him that way in the book
he is a multi-flawed very complicated
human being
and let's face it uh
Saints are less colorful characters to
write about
than people like Ted Turner
but the real question that I wanted to
get at is why does he do these things
people can have money they can do things
but I really wanted to get at the
impetus
and so here he is again at the Flying D
the pond in the background was a wetland
that he created as a wedding present to
Jane Fonda when they married roughly a
dozen years ago
actually 20 something years ago excuse
me
so
this is what we typically think of Ted
Turner this is a photo of him in his
office in Atlanta
he has 50 honorary doctorates he's a a
collector of Civil War artifacts he's
got an Emmy in a World Series on his
desk and bison
he's got fish that he caught with Fidel
Castro and he was labeled a traitor for
going to Cuba he opened a CNN Bureau in
Moscow and and Havana and was pilloried
for it
but this is largely Turner past sense
or past tense excuse me
and what I think is important to do is
to consider the context of Ted Turner
here are two Gilded Age tycoons who were
among the richest of their time on the
left you have Marcus Daly and on the
right you have William Clark
one of the things that's really
interesting about this is you may have
heard that Montana had a version of the
citizens united law that was rejected by
the Supreme Court that actually grew as
a result of the guy on the right
William Clark and Marcus Daly were both
Copper Kings and they presided over the
richest Hill on Earth in America Butte
Montana
you know it was responsible for a huge
percentage of houses that became
electrified
and you know today it would be hundreds
of billions of dollars if you
extrapolated that into today's dollars
so one would expect that Butte Montana
would be a great city today if the
wealth were were kept in that community
in fact
this is a view of Butte today
old Butte is off to the southwest of
that image
this is a photograph of the Berkeley pit
it's it it sits at the headwaters of one
of the largest linear Superfund sites in
the country over 100 million dollars
spent to clean it up it's still ongoing
we as citizens of this country will uh
be part of that to
treat that water in perpetuity
a couple years ago you may have read
about it in Harper's magazine there was
a flock of snow geese flying from Canada
Southward during their Autumn migration
and they landed on the water in the
Berkeley pit and within an hour they
were all dead it's just this super toxic
soup
and so when we think about wealth and
how it's created we also need to think
about externalities
and who's paying those
so here's another Gilded Age Tycoon you
all know of this person John D
Rockefeller Jr
here's something that Rockefeller did
with his money
he used the Snake River Ranch as uh as a
entity that purchased most of the lands
in Grand Teton National Park and
indeeded the ranch of the federal
government Grand Teton as we know it
today wouldn't exist were it not for
those land acquisitions
and here's another one
Andrew Carnegie
and as we all know he he valued literacy
he thought it was one of the most
important tools uh for empowering
citizens and many of us grew up in towns
where there are Carnegie libraries and
what he said is as I grow older I pay
less attention to what men say I just
watch what they do
what how I interpret that how Ted Turner
interprets that is
um don't listen to posers
so here's Ted Turner this is the Ted
Turner we all know and love or hate
the guy who does the tomahawk Chop on
national television with Jane Fonda at
his side along with President Jimmy
Carter
and because of this Ted Turner becomes
known as the mouth of the South
interesting thing about Ted Turner
um
he's in he insulted Pope John Paul he
told a pollock joke in his presence and
then had to issue a press release to
apologize
he once said that Christianity is for
losers
he was taken out of context in that
actually it was sort of Christianity is
for losers if all you do is you wait you
know wait for the Creator to intervene
and tell you what to do but nonetheless
and because of his marriage his 10-year
marriage to Jane Fonda
he's known as a Godless Lefty
or a socialist
that he's plotting with the U.N to rest
away control of private property rights
this is all the stuff that that we hear
and Have Heard on AM radio in the West
some of these I tried to track down and
actually find out when I was a a
journalist at the city news Bureau I
mentioned to some students today the
motto there was if your mother says she
loves you check it out with at least two
independent sources
Turner has left a track record of saying
lots of incendiary things but these are
some of the rumors
another one is that he supports One
World Government
a couple favorites here
is that he enlisted African night pilots
from Nigeria to fly U.N
helicopters to dump wolves into his
property
and another one is that he asked Federal
bear managers to trap the meanest
Grizzlies and dump them onto his flying
D Ranch to ward off trespassers
everybody claims to have a Ted Turner
story and what I've discovered
is that most of them aren't true
there's a great story out there that uh
in fact it's one of the most widely
circulated it's reached millions of
people on the internet that Ted and Jane
went into a a steakhouse in Montana and
they were so indignant when they
couldn't get in
that they raised a stink in the
manager sent them out but with their
tails between their legs and the whole
crowd erupted in cheers for putting them
in their place the thing is it never
happened and there's lots of stories
like that in the west Turner aroused its
stories like that
so who is this guy
in order to understand him and
ultimately his motivation
you have to understand the child and you
have to understand where he came from
now one thing about Ted Turner
that a lot of people don't realize
is that when he was a teenager he wanted
to be an artist this is Ted Turner
with a painting he he painted of his dad
now one of the things about Ed Turner
his father
is that he was a Serial womanizer he
once boasted to Ted that he had slept
with 300 women other than his mother
before he was 30 years old
he was a heavy drinker he was also one
who taught Ted the Mantra early to bed
early to rise work like hell and
advertise
so a couple of things
one of the things Ted Turner's father
told him his son
don't set your goals so low in your
lifetime that you'll meet them all and
one of the or among the three goals that
Ed Turner had bestowed upon or that he
had set for himself was having a million
dollars in the bank owning a yacht and
owning a plantation
and ultimately he was miserable at the
end of his life he had after Ted was
booted out of brown he came back to
Georgia
and he was being groomed to take over
the family billboard company was one of
the largest advertising billboard
companies in the country and had a lot
of billboards in the southeast
and then Ed Turner decided to sell the
company and he didn't tell Ted about it
Ted found out about it second hand
and so Ted called his father and took
him to task
and said Dad you've always taught me
that I should be courageous
well a couple weeks later Ed Turner had
breakfast and read the paper and had a
cigarette and went up to the upstairs
bathroom in his Plantation and put a gun
to his head and pulled the trigger
and so Turner was 24 years old when this
happened there are some people who said
say Ted you should just get over that
but it's something that sense of guilt
that sort of Shame it's something that
Ted Turner carried with him for the rest
of his life and it's also something that
bonded him psychically to Jane Fonda
Jane Fonda's mother also committed
suicide
now an interesting thing about Ted
his father's gone
he starts this dramatic Rescue of the
billboard company that will result in
his media Empire
and he proceeds
to wallpaper
Billboards across the South with this
remember the Godless Lefty
takes this and of course it's the first
line to Atlas Shrugged
so who is Turner
here he is shortly after his dad passed
it's important to think Ted Turner I I
think of Ted Turner as the guy in the
red shorts
he thinks of himself as a consummate
Underdog and I think all of his
Endeavors have have involved that sort
of underdogs challenge
so the surviving Ted Turner something
that he be we recognize him for he
launches this
this bid in the Americas cup and wins it
with his his uh boat courageous
interesting thing about how times have
changed uh from 77 to today the whole
campaign for the first courageous
Victory cost Turner about a quarter of a
million dollars when Larry Ellison and
his uh high-tech catamaran won this year
it cost Ellison 100 million dollars
so here's terrible Ted this is when his
reputation starts to get solidified
people sell them short they say Ted you
can never win the America's Cup
of course this is the Ted Turner that
starts to come on a lot of people's
radar screens on the first of June 1980
he launches CNN in an Old Country Club
the networks say and and you'll never
succeed people say there's no appetite
for 24-Hour news
and he says we won't be signing off
until the world ends
and so CNN goes on the air
this is one of the reasons why Clayton
Christensen uh calls Ted Turner of
Technology disrupter the other reason is
of course is that he hooked a Backwater
cable television channel and created the
superstation and gave us Atlanta Braves
games whether we wanted them
you know all day long
terrible Ted
shakes up the networks
and so I think about again I think about
tycoons I think about modern tycoons and
technology disruptors and outliers and
underdogs and people who do things
the real question is you know what will
happen with the wealth that's was
created by Steve Jobs what kinds of
things did he support
what kinds of things will Zuckerberg
support what is he behind
what sort of obligation do you have when
you become a plutocrat
it's a Ted Turner the question I would
pose liberal or conservative it's funny
but uh
I've spent a few time in the rural
Hinterlands of the West at Rotary clubs
with everybody convinced that Ted Turner
is a liberal and so what I'd like to do
now is go through some aspects of Turner
that I think challenge this notion of
of polemics and and defining people
rigidly one way or the other
so the early 1980s after Turner's father
is long gone
few years after he launched CNN Jacques
Cousteau invites Turner to join him
aboard Calypso it's it's uh docked up
the Amazon River
and they're they're out there at night
they're listening to monkeys and they're
uh the jungles around them and
Cousteau starts laying out the Litany of
problems you know already there's a dead
zone uh identified in the Gulf of Mexico
and there's evidence of coral reefs
being bleached and there's pollution
that Cousteau is confronted and
Ted Turner says Captain I came down here
to be inspired and all you're doing is
bumming me out
and so they were talking about
environmental problems and Cousteau said
Ted you're in the media business you're
in a position to reach and educate lots
of people and bring the problems of the
environment
make them palpable for for people
and he said to Turner and I'll come back
to something later he said what can men
of good conscience do but even if they
know the world's going to end
fight to ensure that that doesn't happen
and so that night was the one when uh
Cousteau leaned on Turner and said you
need to make a difference
and Turner left that it was a pivotal
moment in his life Cousteau becomes not
only a father figure to turn her and
they were great friends for the rest of
cousteau's days but Turner goes back to
Atlanta and he launches the first
environmental reporting division
of any news Outlet
he also opened CNN bureaus around the
world he opens a bureau in Moscow and
for that he's pilloried by the right
for being a traitor two interesting
things
one of them that both Mikhail Gorbachev
and T Boone Pickens whom I interviewed
for the book said they credit Turner
with being a major vehicle with the
collapse of the former USSR what
Gorbachev said is that there it was a
two-way window with Russians and people
in the other Stones they could see into
they could see America and in fact the
station that they had a TV station that
they were turned to in the Pollock
Bureau with CNN
T-Bone Pickens also credited Turner with
that now another thing that happened is
Ted sent his eldest son Teddy to work in
the CNN Bureau and one of the things
Gorbachev said is I knew that Ted Turner
could be trusted and he was a good guy
when he would send his son into what
Ronald Reagan had called the evil empire
interesting footnote here Teddy was in a
car crash that nearly killed him
and he was on the receiving end of
soviet-style Medicine
and from that experience he came back to
the U.S
a a firm antagonist of socialized
medicine
and he also became a watcher his
favorite news channel is Fox
so here's Turner and Gorbachev
later Turner would end up helping
Gorbachev complete his Presidential
Library because he thought it was
important as a symbol Gorbachev had kept
all of his files in a closet in his
small Moscow apartment and Turner
thought it was important that those
should go into a formal repository to
Chronicle the history of the Soviet
Union and so Gorbachev to this day
counts Turner is among one of his best
friends
and we all know
some of you
may not have been born but when CNN
covered the first Gulf War live
as a result of that Turner was named man
of the year now it's Person of the Year
by Time Magazine
but again invention the things we do the
ideas we have and reinvention what do we
want to do when we want to have an
impact a positive impact
and that story in Ted Turner's life
really begins when he comes West
Turner was 50 years old when he bought
his first Ranch his kids said Dad you
need to mellow out a little bit he was
The Chronic workaholic
wasn't around much he he comes to the
West
he picks up his first fly rod when he's
50 years old and learns it and it ends
up changing his life he learns to start
thinking about the landscape from the
water level he starts thinking about
ecosystems it was actually an idea
that had started after he bought his
first Plantation in the late 70s in the
Southeast he bought three bison at an
exotic livestock auction auction and put
them on a plantation
but of course bison are not very happy
in South Carolina in the middle of
summer
and he thought if he really wanted to
build a bison herd he needed to look
West there's another great story
Turner at the same time that he
purchased those bison he had some
cougars and black bears that he kept in
an enclosure in his South Carolina Ranch
and so one night
he brought them all and hauled them over
to another Plantation outside of
Tallahassee and turned them loose
because he wanted to rewild Northern
Florida
one of the Cougars
a woman was driving her car home
a cougar ran out she hit it with her car
and it died
people were shocked because they hadn't
seen a cougar for a long time there and
they tracked Turner down
and they made him promise never to do
that again
and Turner looked West and he said you
know what I want to rewild Landscapes
but I want to have enough land where
those animals won't get into trouble I
want to be above board
and so he comes to the West when he was
a kid he used to rub wooden or rub uh
Buffalo nickels together dreaming that
one day he could have his own herd and
this is really a totemic species for Ted
Turner
so when I interviewed him in 1992
shortly after he had started to cause a
Ruckus there
we were talking about what his plans
were and I asked him what is your vision
and he pointed to this aquatent by Carl
bodmer and he said someday I want my La
my land to look and feel like this
and this is a picture of the flying D
Ranch today the same Ranch five thousand
bison on the property
largest single herd in the world it's
even larger than the wild bison herd in
Yellowstone National Park just down the
road
now a couple things about bison
um they are as you know incredibly
resilient animals
they evolved in this landscape on the
flying D some of the last wild bison
that existed in Montana resided on the
flying d
as you also know we nearly exterminated
them from 30 million plus down to
several hundred
today Turner owns 55 000 bison they're
spread across about a dozen and a half
ranches in the West
so here's another part of Ted Turner
what do you think of when you see that
you know some people will say it's the
flag of the most dysfunctional
bureaucracy in the world
so Turner a couple things happen in Ted
Turner's life at the same time that he's
on his land-being spree
people start are starting to recognize
that he's supporting the UN
and he's scheduled to receive an award
in New York City in the late 1990s
and so he decides to use that
as a a means to make a splash and so he
does two things
he steps up to receive the award and he
announces that he's giving a billion
dollars to the United Nations
at that point the U.S was a billion
dollars in arrears and its membership
dues to the U.N people like Jesse Helms
said we shouldn't pay our dues the U.S
should withdraw from the U.N
and Turner uses it as a a night
to make a show of support at that point
he was worth about three billion dollars
so he gave away a third of his wealth or
pledge to give that away that night
along the way
Turner's properties if you remember this
sequence Time Warner purchased his his
company and then ultimately Time Warner
became part of the AOL Time Warner
merger a few years after this the second
thing that Ted Turner did that night is
he looked out and leaned on fellow
plutocrats and and Forbes Magazine and
he said
along with recognizing people who hoard
their wealth and sit on it in order to
have a place on that list you need to
give back you need to support the
society that's enabled you to prosper
and Kofi Annan told me later that he
enjoyed looking at the startled
Expressions on people's faces and watch
them squirm he told me this great story
of how he uh Anan was visiting the
Sultan of Brunei who has a thousand
rolls-royces in his Fleet
and he said that he had been infected
with guilt thanks to Ted Turner
but why the U.N why step up it's an
incredibly unpopular organization within
certain circles
this is one of the reasons so you have
Ted Turner who started and was developed
by a father who was a
Advocate a a very Goldwater Republican
but one of the things Turner remembers
and all of us do
from history
is that what happened when the League of
Nations went away there was no cohesive
entity to Rally the world
nobody to stand up
70 million people died some estimate 70
percent of them innocent civilians
Turner has a little a favorite parlor
game that he likes to do if you're over
to his house for dinner and you start
voicing suspicion about the U.N he'll
give you a quiz and of course today
when we think about safe air travel when
we think about the world Court when we
think about human rights and we think
about protecting endangered species and
food safety and medicine and controlling
diseases
think about trying
to Foster treaties that promote those
things in today's environment in
Congress
that's something that Ted Turner reminds
people and I think it's a a great point
to make
so this is our world today and for the
students here
we need to be thinking about
and I think about this as a journalist
what's a way to make people think about
the issues
Turner is an inveterate environmentalist
and one of the things he says it's
immoral to ignore the widening gap
between the Haves and the have-nots and
what does that look like
here's one View
it's great if you can live on the right
side of the fence it's not so great if
you live on the left side of the fence
one of the reasons that Turner gave a
billion dollars to the U.N and part of
their funding mechanism he couldn't give
it directly to the U.N so he created the
UN Foundation
one of the thing ways that they do it is
they try to Marshal campaigns to address
specific issues instead of just throwing
money this year
Turner's last tranche of a hundred
million dollars will be paid off to
fulfill that billion dollars but in
terms of leveraged value it's been
leveraged tenfold of that initial
billion dollar stake and what the UN
foundation's been able to do
and so you think about this an interest
another interesting thing
Turner's relationship with Jane Fonda
Ted Turner taught Jane Fonda how to hunt
and fish
how to skin a mule deer that she shot
and cook prepared for dinner and to have
respect for the Second Amendment this is
stuff that's shocking to those people on
AM radio it kind of leaves them disarmed
no pun intended
but one of the things that Jane Fonda
did is she built in Ted Turner a
profound appreciation
for the plight of women especially girls
around the world she brought that onto
her radar screen Ted Turner will tell
you that he's really sorry that he
wasn't conscious and awake enough to get
involved with the Civil Rights Movement
in Atlanta during the 60s but he said
he's he wants to spend the rest of his
years making up for that so this could
be a sister it could be a daughter it
could be a granddaughter and it is
somebody's sister or daughter or
granddaughter so what do we do with this
Turner was born in 1938 a few months ago
he turned 75
2 billion people roughly in 1938
somewhere around 7 billion today
by the middle of this century
some have said nine and a half billion
possibly by the end of this Century what
11 billion
and so out in Montana people don't think
much about how open space is being
filled up but as you all know
most people are going to be living in
mega cities
and if we consume resources according to
our standard of living we're going to
need another planet
and we also know
that during times of tension
particularly with more countries being
added to the nuclear Club
that the dangers rise and so
another thing about Ted Turner um at the
turn of the millennium
Turner through those mergers of the
media companies he was worth somewhere
around 11 billion dollars he owned a
hundred million shares of AOL Time
Warner stock at about a hundred dollars
a share and then the company
started to go downhill on the stock
value Tanked
around the same time Charlie Curtis who
then was with Senator Tim worth in
overseeing the UN Foundation
they were talking about nuclear issues
and Turner had assumed that you know
with the collapse of the Berlin wall and
and the former Soviet Union that nuclear
threats had gone away and
Charlie Curtis disabused him of that and
said you know not not only do we have
thousands of weapons between the U.S and
Russia pointed at each other on hair
trigger alert but if you really want to
become afraid
you need to be thinking about the threat
of of suitcase nukes with all of this
unsecured nuclear material in the
nuclear labs in the former USSR
and in one case they mounted this rescue
where Ted actually ponyed up several
million dollars and they launched a
Commando raid to go in and secure the
material that could be used another
person Graham Allison whom I interviewed
he's at Harvard
reminds us that the 9 11 attacks
that wasn't the original intent of the
terrorists to fly planes into
skyscrapers the original plan and hope
was to get their hands on a Suitcase
nuke and in the book I have Turner and
Graham Allison talking about what would
happen if a 10 kiloton
suitcase nuke a Sidewinder were
detonated in in Times Square
as Senator Sam Nunn who was a co-founder
of the nuclear threat initiative with
Turner says you know the real
interesting scenario that they've
discussed is not only if you detonate
one suitcase nuke but what if you have
another one
and say you detonate that
and then
you threatened to to detonate another
one in another city and you can
literally hold cities hostage
and as Graham Allison says every notion
of sort of psychic stability that we
have as a society would be I mean think
about that think about the flight from
cities
and the real thing of course is to get
at the motivation of why do people hate
us
it's one of the one of the fundamental
tenets of Ted Turner is to think about
that and be sympathetic to that
so during that time
the Free Fall of the stock Turner lost
the equivalent of 10 million dollars a
day every day for two years
and he was roundly attacked by a lot of
people who said you're so bone-headed
you know you're such a jackass why did
you hold on to your shares and not get
out of the company and his response was
when I built my when I built CNN and TBS
as an owner of a company you hold on to
the shares you know
you're not getting out of out of the
stock and you're not going to leave your
own shareholders holding the bag and so
Turner's Fortune collapses
couple weeks after 9 11.
I should say that during 9 11 he was in
Atlanta
his company now was part of this this uh
larger conglomerate and Turner was being
frozen out of his company by Jerry Levin
and Steve case
and Turner realized that he had no home
left at CNN and so later that fall as
this
colossal loss was happening as he said
it was the most severe loss of personal
fortune in history Turner thought of
taking his own life
he was out in Montana at the Flying D
and decided and decided not to do that
but a big part of it was related to this
he had a contingency plan that might
have forced him to back out of his
commitments to these Charities and also
start selling the ranches which he he
was fearful of
so about this same time he gets a call
from this guy
this guy's been out of prison
one of the things that Nelson Mandela
did soon after release is he promoted
the idea of Peace Parks got involved in
the peace Park movement and set up a
trans Boundary Park with five nations in
southern Africa
and he knew of Turner's reputation and
he said Ted I have a special assignment
for you I'd like to go
to this part of the world I I've got
other things that I have to work on but
I'd like you to work on this one of the
people who was helping him was Mike
Finley the former superintendent of
Yellowstone Yosemite
and the Everglades and Finley took over
as head of the Turner foundation and so
they went to South Korea
and as you know the Korean DMZ about 150
some miles long
interesting thing about this
is that within this Corridor
conservation biologists will say
that they believe it's one of the
last vestiges or last places of Refuge
for
Korean tigers
an amort leopards and other species
there so you have in this no man's land
you have this Nature Preserve and one of
another belief of Turner is is that
friends don't blow each other up he
believes that opposing sides should get
together
and so this peace part concept has
gained traction today between the the
koreas whether they Embrace that that's
another thing but you can think about
the peace part concept for example
between Israel and Palestine
between India and Pakistan
between a lot of countries that are in
Conflict particularly countries now with
nukes
of trying to use nature as a social glue
to bring people together this is
something that Turner is behind
something else related to the UN
Foundation marshalling of campaigns you
know I showed this this photo to
different
groups
and a lot of young people I think I as a
at the tail end of the baby boomer
getting those polio shots
we remember having our grandparents and
parents who who suffered from polio and
as
you know today
it's not polio is now limited to just
Island pockets and just as it's
important to save species it can also be
important to eradicate organisms
the polio plus campaign that's part of
Rotary International and a bunch of
partners that Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation the Turner Foundation
that close to eradicating polio
another thing bed nets for about 10
bucks you can change the trajectory of a
life
just by adding protection to mosquitoes
as a way of malaria prevention 10 bucks
you can change somebody's life
so Ted Turner liberal or conservative
and so we return to the West this is Ted
Turner
riding through his bison herd at the
Flying D Ranch
one of the things that's interesting
about Turner this evolution of an
eco-capitalist humanitarian
is that he really sees an opportunity to
manage his land Holdings as arcs for
imperiled species to show that this sort
of dichotomy of environment versus
economy is a false dichotomy
and he has offered Sanctuary to a lot of
endangered species in the west again if
you listen to AM radio people will say
if you Harbor an endangered species on
your land it's going to cost you the
bottom line you may be run out of
business and Turner has just said
hogwash to that
here's one of his properties an island
called Saint Phillips island off the
coast uh just south of Charleston
and as many of you know that's a sea
turtle crawl
hatchlings will go out to sea and
sometimes they'll return many many years
later
to the same nesting site and lay their
eggs but if there are condos there the
habitat isn't there if they survive this
Gauntlet of threats in the ocean
it's one of the reasons why uh sea
turtle populations are in trouble but
Turner is is
helping to protect them another thing
he's got one of the largest bat caves in
the country on one of his ranches in New
Mexico
two interesting things about about this
one is Mikhail Gorbachev was visiting
there and he went back to Russia and
became a firm advocate for bat
conservation
and uh Gorbachev while he's been out
with Turner once was walking with them
and uh
Ted was walking his dog intended to the
the dog after it had relieved itself and
Gorbachev sort of braced from that and
Turner bent down and picked up trash and
Gorbachev said what are you doing you
put it in his truck in his pocket and
you know Turner said nobody is too big
to do to do this are you too big to pick
up trash and so Gorbachev started
picking up trash and he went back to
Moscow
and his daughter Arena saw that and said
dad what are you doing and Gorbachev
said nobody's too big to pick up trash
and she has taught that to Gorbachev's
grandkids and so just these little
things these little weird quirks that
Ted Turner has it's sort of part of his
ethic and it's something that rubs off
on people in in profound and unexpected
ways
another species that Turners help
protect the red caucated woodpecker
on one of his plantations he's
transplanted or tried to restore
longleaf pine
a million seedlings there and the red
caucated woodpecker is sort of an
emblematic species of the Safe Harbor
program of the U.S fish and wildlife
service
land owners know that when they offer
Habitat to imperiled species they're not
going to be punished by the government
and he's helped bring back an offer
Sanctuary to chirakawa leopard frogs
amphibians are in trouble
and to the Bolson tortoise
a cousin to the giant Galapagos tortoise
these were ABS this is an example of
post pleistocene rewild and people think
about it when they hear in conservation
biology circles that Ted Turner wants to
bring back saber-toothed tigers
what he has in mind more are these
toothless
Critters
these were absent from the U.S for
Millennia surviving only in Mexico and
they restored the restoring populations
and Bolson tortoises on a couple of its
ranches
so Yellowstone National Park that's just
down the road from where I live it's a
center of the greater Yellowstone
ecosystem 18 million Acres
why am i showing this and the abundance
of wildlife there it's
you know the last and biggest intact
ecosystem
it's got all of these animals and if you
look at a checklist of Yellowstone the
same checklist that exists in
Yellowstone exists just up the road at
the Flying D Ranch Ted has all the major
mammal species that were there at the
end of the pleistocene of course if
you're not including giant sloths and
saber-toothed tigers but they're all
there this was this was Turner after I
paid my the first Ranch that I ever
visited apart from the Montana Ranch is
where his Estancia is in Argentina and I
flew back North with him
and he couldn't wait to get back to
Montana because there had been wolves
cited on the property dispersers from
that first effort to reintroduce wolves
in the early 1990s
this is actually a photo of wolves in
Yellowstone
but today the flying D is home to the
largest one of the largest wolf packs in
the lower 48 the bear trap pack has 20
some members on it
Turner's one of the few ranches Ranch
owners in the west to not pull the
trigger and manage wolves
and they get back to bison as resilient
species bison are more Predator
resistant
Turner has grizzly bears on his land and
he has wolves on his land
and unlike a lot of cattle ranchers
these guys need less protection they're
hardier
hardier and dry weather conditions
and I want to throw some figures at you
four feet
twenty two thousand
and 40.
so to decode this
four feet of snow fell in South Dakota
last
September
22 000 cattle died
1400 sheep
300 horses
40 bison
now Granite cattle exists
in far greater number in South Dakota
but this also speaks to the hardiness of
Bison that have endured
profound fluctuations in climate
they have a competitive advantage that a
lot of people are just waking up to when
Turner first got into the Bison business
there were somewhere around a
I don't know 50 000 bison
today there are half a million bison and
so Turner is at the Forefront of this
bison Renaissance
and on its High Plains ranches he's
restored prairie dog colonies and he's
hated for that in the West
why why is he doing it
what value do these guys have
you know and a lot of ranches ranchers
uh
either recruit hunters or have hunters
pay to go out and just blow these
animals away or they're engaged in
broadcast poisoning today the
black-tailed prairie dog once one of the
most prolific prairie dog species exists
on just two percent of its range here's
a startling statistic a guy named Mike
Gilpin who's a specializes in population
Dynamics
in 1804 when Lewis and Clark came into
the West
the biomass of prairie dogs in the
American West was equal to the combined
biomass of Humanity on the planet
so what about that biomass what does it
feed just like the fish in Ocean
ecosystems
well you wouldn't have these guys
Dr Susan Clark who knows if she would be
involved in conservation biology today
if these guys weren't rescued from
Extinction and they held on because
there were Remnant prairie dogs
and you tend not to have burrowing owls
in such abundance
or Swift foxes
or a couple dozen related obligate and
and associated species
keystone species you get a big bang for
the buck and Turner over his lifetime
has gone from being a proud
protector of ten thousand prairie dogs
to now a quarter of a million of them
and so today's world
this is this is the fact this is
this is the world you're inheriting
and as you know
some areas are going to become
hotter and drier in the west where we
are Dr Steve running who was part of
that Nobel P won the Nobel Peace Prize
along with Al Gore
if you look at a one centigrade increase
he talks about the percentage of
moisture that we'll need to increase to
offset that but if you look at the
computer models in these dry land
farming and ranching regions the West
isn't going to receive more moisture in
fact all this snow I wish we could bring
it back to us in Montana because we're
not having a very big snow year there
and what that means is a lot of forest
fires
so Turner's thinking about this he's
thinking about the advantages of Bison
he's thinking about why big Landscapes
are better why they're more resilient in
the time of climate change
and we think about the costs
we think about where all the food's
going to come from to feed people
we think about in the west the cost of
fighting
wildfires that are going through the
roof
we think about this pine bark beetles
we have a cabin just west of Bozeman and
we've watched the forest around the
place just turn rust colored and then
die
big big fires
and these guys going through two
reproductive Cycles in the course of a
year
instead of just one you know it takes 35
to minus 35 degrees for a week or longer
to kill them
and they are robust these days
we think about Los Angeles and Southern
California and we think about the fires
there and we think about the coasts
and people are saying adapt adaptive
management
and we think about externalities of bad
decisions
and so in Montana today in the Powder
River base in Wyoming is now the largest
coal producing state Montana is about to
come online near where I am we talk
about the Keystone Pipeline but in terms
of real carbon coming out of the ground
in our own backyard not from Canada
this is one of the game changers and a
big part of this
is Bound for export to China its
interest in the politicians in Montana
Ted gets together with them fairly often
and he asks them so let me get this
straight you condemn the Chinese
for not having a policy to combat
climate change and yet you're feeding
them the coal
and whether or not you whether or not
you buy into the fact that climate
change is human caused or not it's still
happening
so the question is what do we do about
this
how do you reinvent yourself when
Turner's been to Wharton and Stanford
and other business schools he's often
asked Ted what would you do if you
wanted to become a tycoon today and
Turner says
I'd get into Alternative Energy
and so on his ranches he has alternative
solar power there he does energy Audits
and carbon audits you know that the fact
is the guy flies around in a personal
aircraft and has been vilified by the
right wing just as Al Gore has and one
of the ways that he deals with hypocrisy
Turner believes he said listen
if you're going to be a hypocrite
hypocrite
don't let it paralyze you if you're
going to be an environmentalist you're
going to have hypocrisies and just don't
let it take you out of the game but try
to do more each day than the impacts
you're inflicting and so that's
something that Turner has done and it's
a fairly simple premise if we all did
something a little better I know this
sounds corny
but think about the difference
that would be in the world and so one of
the ways that Turner tries to offset his
carbon footprint in addition to managing
his grasslands and keeping them healthy
in his Forest is he's gotten big into
solar
on one of his ranches
he has this grid of 500 000 solar panels
that's what it looks like he's been
condemned by conservationists for the
the footprint
of this solar installation
and so by the end of this decade he
hopes to be providing enough solar power
for a hundred thousand homes
and that's that's what it looks like
you know it's interesting he has gotten
in ferocious debates with Bobby Kennedy
Jr about
you know the opposition
to those wind
windmills off the coast of Massachusetts
and he said you know it said you need to
step up to the plate
and accept impacts if you want to
address the real problem
and so Cousteau and Turner
it's the late 1990s now and
Turner has green lighted a movie Project
a making
of the film Gettysburg and they're at
the National Theater in Washington DC
they're watching it on an old old film
and that the real breaks and they're
they're there it's a crowded Auditorium
and Turner's next to Cousteau and
cousteau's Son Jean-Michel is off to his
left and Turner's kids are there
and they start talking about
environmental problems and Ted's talking
about things and Cousteau turns to
Turner and says
Ted you worry too much
you need to relax
and Cousteau said
you know I've come to a point in my life
where I've given up I I don't think
there is any hope for Humanity I think
you're wasting your time what I'm seeing
is there's too much complacency
young people aren't up to the challenge
he goes on and he gives this litany
and Turner turn turns to him and puts
his hand on his and cousteau's hand and
says Captain I can't accept that if
there's even a three percent chance to
have Reason for Hope
that's the bet that I want to make
and so they're watching this people are
leaning forward they want to listen to
this conversation because they can't
believe it
and so Turner leans on Cousteau and says
you know what you've just said to me is
completely unacceptable
and so what John Michelle Cousteau who
is was also born in 38 and is a
contemporary of Turners he said that is
that there was this element of
transference that occurred that the the
young grasshopper that the young Protege
had become the mentor
and a few months later when Cousteau was
on his death pad he rallied
and he said I'm not afraid to die but I
want to be around long enough to make a
difference
I think it's really interesting one of
the things that's really important to
Turner is to is to inspire young people
to rise up and accept the challenges and
again it sounds pretty cornball but it's
absolutely true he has hope
and he really is turning to look at at
you to make a difference you know Turner
has said cynically
that we only have 50 years to get our
arms around these problems and he's been
leaning on fellow plutocrats
not long ago E.O Wilson was visiting and
Turner had 10 of the largest landowners
in the west that cumulatively have
control of 12 million Acres that are in
between the public lands out there and
knowing how important big Landscapes are
technological resilience he's enlisted a
bunch of these and a bunch of these are
very very conservative individuals who
have now been brought into landscape
conservation and so
you know we think about Richard Dawkins
and and his discussions of memes
Paul Ehrlich told me that he looks at a
Turner as a sort of meme a way of
thinking about how we can change
Behavior
again Turner isn't perfect
and so we come to the triple bottom line
you know we hear Paul or Paul Hawken
talk about the triple bottom line and
how we need it different
different kind of accounting system and
so the triple bottom line one leg of the
stool is economic sustainability unless
things are economically sustainable on
private land they're not going to
persist Turner himself realizes
that if he's going to pass on his lands
to the his next Generation it better be
sustainable so it's not a debt
proposition or bad things will happen to
the land desperate people do desperate
things with their land and so the first
leg is economic sustainability one of
Turner's other mantras is faster better
cheaper built on the maxim of NASA he
doesn't want to wait around for
government to do the right thing the
second leg of the stool is ecological
sustainability is either Do no harm
or pull your money back in to make
Landscapes better restore them don't
foist externalities off on the public to
have to pay and the third one is the
human aspect of pay your your employees
a livable wage treat them well and try
and keep
the money that you're spending in local
communities let that trickle down and
today despite a lot of antagonism
directed at Turner when he started
buying up these lands as this wealthy
Outsider this jackass
people love him out in the west because
he funnels millions of dollars into
local economies to keep these ranches
viable
and so here's Ted Turner's family he
puts a lot of stock in his family he was
not the most attentive father growing up
and one of the reasons why he created
the Turner Family Foundation is as a way
to bring his kids into the
decision-making process and to get
closer you have Rhett who's a filmmaker
based in Atlanta he does Wildlife
documentaries you have Laura Seidel who
together with her husband Rutherford
Seidel they're the real deal as far as
activists
you have Jenny who's been involved in
media she lives in Lexington
Kentucky you have teddy the guy who was
assigned to the CNN Moscow Bureau
some of you may have known that he ran
against that governor who famously went
for a walk on the Appalachian Trail
from South Carolina he was beaten by
Mark Sanford in in a race for congress
but he's entered politics considers
himself a hook and bullet Republican and
then you have Bo
who is the Sportsman among them most
like Ted Ted doesn't hunt anymore
but Rhett has overseen many of the
wildlands and what's interesting while I
was writing this book I always thought
there was this looming fear
what happens if Turner just breaks up
his land and and the foundations go away
I will look like a goat
but Turner and his will has he's going
to funnel all of his money back into the
foundations and to keep the ranch as
viable as you know he's been a major
force in the giving pledge
uh conservative and and Progressive
plutocrats have agreed to give away half
of their wealth before they die so he
still leans on people
so here's a quote Surplus wealth is a
sacred trust which its possessor is
bound to administer in his lifetime for
the good of the community
Trotsky who
and it's this is Andrew Carnegie and
Carnegie said you know you spend I I
don't know is it Carnegie or Carnegie
he said you spend the first half of your
life accruing wealth in the second half
giving it away
you know and Turner says those Gilded
Age tycoons Justified
some pretty bad stuff on the land in
order to amass their fortunes
and if you don't buy that that you can
buy this
and so here we are
you can't evict in an idea capitalism
it's not going away
as Turner will say but we need to devise
a better alternative
so Ted Turner invents Captain Planet
takes great Delight in the fact that
Rush Limbaugh feels threatened by this
children's cartoon character
one thing about Ted Turner during his
programming at CNN as he was making a
had a documentary made about
clear-cutting in the Northwest and the
timber industry threatened to boycott
CNN and withdraw its ads and it was
scheduled to run once a week and Ted
Turner said screw him I want it to run
every night for the next month
and so he stands on his principles and
that the theme of Captain Planet is the
power is yours
but Turner's a big fan of this book
hands it out to people whenever he can
and of course
one of the lines from The Lorax is it's
not about what it is it's about what it
can be
it's about believing in yourself as
underdogs change doesn't it always
happens through underdogs
and Turner believes that the most
important relationship we're going to
have besides the one that we have with
loved ones is our connection to the land
and of course the LA one of the last
lines of The Lorax is unless you care a
whole awful lot nothing is going to get
better it's not
and so I hope that when you go out there
you you become those
eco-capitalists because we have a lot of
problems
and uh
it's just been a great Delight coming
here so thanks for coming in please I
hope there's some questions
foreign